I feel like you have a lot of analysis
but like you don't really not like
connecting you don't really know it's
like going towards I would actually just
cut this entire section where you would
feel that I should probably go issues in
my options a student when we think about
peer review it's useful actually to have
a sense of how central it is there's
kind of peer review that happens in the
classroom where peer students other
people just like you are looking at your
work and you're looking at theirs now in
a professional level that person might
be appear it might be somebody you've
never met you might be the preeminent
scholar in your field and your peer
might be somebody quite junior peer
itself just that term is very open-ended
it's basically anybody else engaged in
the same project you're engaged in
trying to understand these basic
questions of discipline there's always a
need to have somebody else tell you
where you're going off course nobody
writes alone nobody finishes work alone
peer review is really the feedback
mechanism about the quality of our ideas
and how well we communicate and that's
really how academic work moves forward
[Music]
the response to one's work in whatever
form it takes is always crucial you want
to simply people to like your work but
you also really want to get you know a
qualitative understanding of whether or
not your work is doing what you intended
to do and whether it's satisfying some
requirements of your audience I wasn't
taught how to do peer review it can be a
very mysterious process and certainly a
scary one which is why we need to talk
more about how it's done and what it
involved very hard to understand the
process until you've done both sides
you've actually done the reviewing and -
as well as received the reviewing I've
talked to all of you I think in
conference now on this paper so you've
gotten my feedback and today's peer
review is for you to share feedback with
each other students in my class working
on each other's draft what they were
doing was really helping the writers
produce these ideas to their best
possible level I thought you could
probably combine the first paragraph I
think I know you're trying to get up I
feel like you took two more plate too
long to explain it if your students
beginning the process of peer review and
you're uncertain about what you might
say is somebody I think one thing to
remember is that what you're really
doing is providing the experience of a
reader if you keep that in mind you
can't really go wrong it was personal
but they were going to personal that it
was on if you like return
I tell students that they get to say I
liked it only once per class they have
to understand that there are
collaborators here and that you know
it's important to notice what's going to
work but you have to be focused and
specific restriction here I might edit
to be a little less inflammatory we've
all had some experience with peer review
that isn't positive whether that getting
reviews on our own work or being put on
the spot to say something when we're not
quite sure what we think yet there is a
difference between saying this piece of
writing doesn't work and you're a bad
person incumbent of course on the
teacher to make sure that that
distinction never gets you know never
gets forgotten in the classroom neutral
and you can forgive the effect of the
situation in a way which creates
negativity in the readers mind but at
the same time the documentation is
reflective when you're beginning to get
peer review what that probably means is
you are beginning not only to learn the
process of peer review but you're
beginning to learn the process of
understanding whatever it is that you're
reviewing that's a perfect time to also
begin peer review not to wait until
you're an expert but to start at that
point where everything is new where
you're beginning because when you have
the best questions you have them the
most capacity to recognize features and
to ask about them really freshly seeking
things using the term social action
blame the effect that that has an
audience would be a good conclusion and
Lansing coming into this cost I have the
notion that if I dedicated more and more
time by myself to a certain essay that
that was going to perfect it but you
know really just one word or one
sentence from someone else can open up
possibilities for me that I would never
realize no matter how long I spent
because it's a professional requirement
peer review can seem like a mechanical
exercise but my experience more and more
has been that it's a tremendously
creative endeavor and and done well is
as important to the intellectual process
of the work it's the one place where the
author's work becomes truly
collaborative its central and it
permeates everything we do in academia
if you see the photo to be strong magnet
so that is what doesn't have some sense
of how you people think about allow you
to respond said it helps us get better
at all the other actually perform in
academia it helps us get better at
learning the methods at creating ideas
peer review keeps us on our toes it
complicates and enriches our thinking
and you know the best possible thing in
the world of a smart person really
looking at your work with that depth and
regard such that if you listen to what
they say and work with it you you and
your work becomes better my writing
isn't the best and I know that and when
people point it out to me it's all the
surprises and today they actually showed
me how I could actually fix my essay
which was quite constructive and
hopefully when I go back and look over
my say I'll be able to
fix those errors which will place a
factory up there
[Music]
[Music]